The Joe Rogan Experience So speaking of
we're humans like tell me about this
Lyme disease thing man because I'm
terrified of Lyme disease yeah it's a
[ __ ]
um so I uh like 2015
uh I started feeling like [ __ ] you know
and it was like joint pain
was getting some uh like neuropathy I
I'd sit on the floor with my kids and my
legs would fall asleep or you know like
just positional [ __ ] and it's like I
[ __ ] my neck up in 2014 uh like 10
days before I fought Yancy Maderos
um so I was like okay my neck's banged
up like like a bulging disc
um I don't even really know the MRI no I
didn't get an MRI it was ten days before
the fight uh it was the most
unspectacular thing it was like a
whiplash injury uh I uh I was sparring
uh Mickey golf when he was like 22 21
and uh he threw like a hook and I just
clinched a body lock and my head hit his
his chest and it just tweaked to my left
and like I felt it I have it on video
and it's like
I'm like shrug my shoulders moved my
heck around it was the last round of the
day I was like all right this is gonna
hurt later but we're gonna get through
it
um
like I only got to that fight because of
you know a chiropractor and his magic
fingers uh and some graston uh but uh so
like a lot of the symptoms that I was
getting
um from the lime I attribute it to being
a fighter I'm like my knees hurt of
course they [ __ ] hurt like uh you
know I mean to the point where I'd be 45
minutes into a training session and have
to get up like an old man push it on my
knees and stuff like that it's getting
you know numbness and tingling uh I was
getting like brain fog and it was pretty
good I kind of like go into a room
sometimes and like go to like clean up
and just kind of get lost
um so uh
before my fight at 196
um like it got so bad that I was like I
was contemplating retirement at UFC 200
I was like I'm gonna get through 196.
I'm gonna ask to fight on 200 to retire
um
and uh you did not know you had did not
know I had Lyme disease
um you know like I said I
the nervous system was was kind of shot
um joints were swollen I'd get some
twitching in my eye was mostly where I'd
get it just for like days on end
um
very occasionally I would
say the wrong word while I was speaking
and not even anything close like just
the complete wrong word would come out
um
and you know you notice and you're like
what the [ __ ] did I just say like they
didn't notice
um
so I was telling my doctor about this uh
before my pre-5 physical uh or during my
prefight physical for 196 and he's like
you know he's like honestly I think you
have Lyme disease
and I was like all right you know so we
we ran some tests test me for Lyme
um to this day I still don't test
positive it's about 50 of the people uh
on that have lime test positive for it
um so he's like
uh if it's Lyme disease you know and
he's like we ran some other tests
there's some antibody that I had that
showed infection that they associate
sometimes with Lyme
um
she's like we're gonna put you on doxy
and he's like if if you do have Lyme
disease within you know a week 10 days
he's like you're gonna feel different
you know what is it called doxy
doxycycline doxycycline
um
so like I fight uh fight Diego and that
was the first time like I was I was kind
of out of it I barely trained for that
fight
um like I would I would
miss training sessions like live
grappling sessions or sparring sessions
and like because I could barely get out
of bed or like uh so I was I I would I
would get in maybe six sessions a week
um you know and kind of just focused on
like all right well just be in shape you
know like I could run on the treadmill
let's the easiest thing for me to do at
that point was to run on the treadmill
which is weird it's different than what
most people experience most people
experience uh difficulty doing aerobic
exercise and uh they can do anaerobic
stuff I couldn't do anaerobic stuff like
if I lifted uh or did Sprints I'd be
banged up for [ __ ] days
um
so
and and that fight like
I remember like when I when I fight
and I think it it has to do something
with the lights too like I don't see the
cage like beyond the cage I don't see
anybody in the stands I don't I barely
hear my [ __ ] corner for crying out
loud
um
so
that fight I the whole during the whole
fight I could see like throughout in the
stands you know I was so like unfocused
um
that like it was just it was a weird
experience it's the only time it's ever
happened to me
um
but I get out of the fight uh
and uh and get on some doxycycline uh
the following week and it was like
within
a week or so just like my doctor said I
started feeling way [ __ ] better
um it took me a few years to figure out
when exactly I got bit I had assumed
that it was probably early 2015 and then
after learning about uh
you know the early symptoms of Lyme
disease and pulling my head out of my
ass remembering the experience that I
had in 2013 it I'm I'm a pretty much 100
confident that I Was Bitten like late
May early June of 2013. what makes you
think though uh I had a period of time
where I was like I basically had morning
sickness I was extremely nauseous in the
morning
um
and and like early lime it's like
flu-like symptoms and and migraines and
stuff like that and so I had really bad
nausea like if I picked up my coffee cup
and I was like breathing in and I got a
big whiff of my coffee I'd it would make
me gag really yeah uh like brushing my
teeth I'd [ __ ] just take the taste of
like the toothpaste would make me gag uh
I had two kids in in Diapers at the time
every time bringing the freaking garbage
out oh man I'd be dry heaving the whole
way down the down the driveway for like
two weeks and I was like my kids are in
daycare I think my my niece had like
rotavirus or something at the time I was
like I got a stomach bug like whatever
um and then I got a series of migraines
like right kind of as the the nausea was
dying down I got I don't know if I think
it was like seven migraines in 10 days
or something like that so
I went to uh neurologist in ENT ran a
bunch of tests they tested me for Lyme
tested negative uh they couldn't find
anything so they're like hey let's just
we're gonna we're gonna kick the ball
down the road a little bit see if it
comes back and you know uh and and
figure out what we can do
um so that I kind of forgot about that
um and uh after you know kind of
educating myself online after I uh you
know was diagnosed uh I was like huh
maybe you know maybe that's when it was
um but it took it took a while to get
over because it was
you know just about three years that it
had
untreated uh you know and and the
bacteria is a sneaky little [ __ ] uh
they call it the great imitator because
it can give everybody completely
different symptoms
um
and it can pass the blood-brain barrier
and and this all this other [ __ ] you
know
um
it also has a uh like a toxin in the
cell wall of it so if you kill too much
of it at one time or in a short period
of time you experience what's called
like the herxheimer reaction uh which is
basically you're being like poisoned by
the death of the Lyme bacteria yeah it's
a it's a shitty
it makes it it makes you it's it's a
[ __ ] amazing thing because it's like
here's this little thing that this
little bacteria that when it dies it
makes you
change what you're doing so that you
don't like it's a getting over line is
especially like
like untreated for a while is a marathon
and I'm not good at that [ __ ]
um
so like I I was on doxycycline for six
months
um you know I ended up six months yeah
and then it's uh that's an antibiotic
yeah it's an antibiotic I was I was I
was [ __ ] [ __ ] like four to five
times before noon I mean in in 2016. so
leading up to like I started to lose a
little weight in 2015 but uh I used to
walk just under a buck 90.
um
after that first six months on
doxycycline I will I was walking around
at 163 pounds uh before the Thiago Alves
fight whoa yeah I lost a [ __ ] ton of
muscle and of course it's like oh it's
usada Jim's off the sauce you know it's
like no I'm pooping so much like you
have no idea uh that like I just can't
keep up with it but um but you were
still fighting I was still fighting yeah
that's crazy so but that's not we're not
even done Joe
so uh I was on it for six months and uh
I felt way better you know that was
whatever it was uh September
um then I did you know in in March so I
was like hey Doc like do you think we
can you know get off of the the
antibiotics and he's like yeah let's
give it a try and it was about seven
weeks and then I started to feel like my
symptoms were coming back
um and then me being an [ __ ] and like
no no they're not like it's it's not
it's not the lime again so like I kind
of waited and
by the end of the year uh it [ __ ]
kicked my ass
um like leading up into uh
what was that 208 uh when I fought
Dustin like that was that was the
hardest couple weeks before a fight that
I've I've ever had like I
because I was trying to get back on the
doxycycline I was trying to to
supplement even way better and you know
you're not supposed to take it within
two hours like two hours before two
hours after supplements and stuff like
that and
like I don't like working out with food
in my stomach so and I can't take the
doxy on an empty stomach because it
didn't you know makes my stomach upset
so uh so I was like trying to figure out
like the best way to get back on it and
it just kept kicking my butt and kicking
my butt um
finally like
I don't know maybe two weeks before the
fight I started to kind of get it get it
dialed in uh and then unfortunately I
was like fight week I was uh I was
having a hercs uh reaction and and uh it
was a really weird experience
getting uh
I was I was having like muscle Tremors
when I was cutting weight so like I was
sitting there
I like punching yeah yeah I couldn't
stop couldn't stop my arm from moving
wow like he's got to be freaky my my
vision was a little messed up and I
don't know if it was the lights or
whatever but like when I fought Dustin
that night like every to me like
everything kind of had like a a yellow
Hue to it it was weird
um and I don't know if that was just my
eyes being weird or what but so this is
the side effect of the virus exuding a
poison yeah yeah because I I finally
like kind of figured it out uh like
right right before that fight
um
so then
like 2017 was uh like I was still
dealing with it and
it it was it was difficult like the
first half of the year was pretty
difficult
um and then like through the through the
summer
um
it's it started to like get a lot better
for me uh
you know I changed my diet I started
eating a lot like a lot better food I
mean like when I first found out I had
lime we were trying to like
it kind of adhere to the lime diet you
know the lime lime diet is like
basically a Paleo it's a it's an
inflammatory disease so avoiding alcohol
sugar gluten uh dairy stuff like that
but it's like I also had a bunch of
little kids and it's like well if I'm
making my food and trying to make their
food so they're not eating mac and
cheese hot dogs and chicken fingers
every day like this is gonna be really
[ __ ] hard so you know like I've never
like adhere to that diet like
specifically but
totally eat a ton more like Whole Foods
and vegetables and [ __ ] like that now so
uh and definitely like I eat way or
drink way less you know so how did you
get off how did you kill the lime is it
is it 100 done or do you still have like
relapses I haven't had a relapse uh uh
since yeah about
2017 yeah oh that's nice so five [ __ ]
years yeah Freedom yeah um so you went
through it for a sense essentially like
a solid four years a few years yeah so
it was uh well like it it took a while
for it to start kicking my butt you know
like I had that first instance in 2013
when it was when I first got bit
but then like I couldn't really tell
anything you know but if you had gotten
on antibiotics right then you probably
could have killed yeah yeah three to
three to four weeks uh is usually
um what doctors will uh you know
prescribed uh and if you catch it early
you usually
fare pretty well with it um
but like yeah I was uh
I mean 2017
I didn't feel like I could start really
like
excuse me uh like pushing myself and and
sprinting and lifting again until like
maybe April of 2018